hallo mein name ist luke an meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen hier heute
am dienstag zu einer neuen episode
ich würde sagen wir fangen wir mit den
besten tik tok der woche plötzlich ist
zu kalt oder schon ganz gut sagen dass
ich eine neue freundin habe
wir denken jetzt schon seit monaten
verstehen uns total gut und wer hat
dieses video eigentlich nicht
vorgeschlagen bekommen
das hat fast 30 millionen aufrufe
mittlerweile
[Musik]
warum bekomme ich sowas auf meiner
homepage
irgendwie leid der kann dies erfordert
der fed ist man so geht der db sehen
[Musik]
was rtl möchte seine schauspieler zurück
ich bin gerade einfach mal durch dieses
loch gefallen
ja dieses noch kann so was passieren
vielleicht schon zu oft seien es aber
egal warum bekomme ich so dass angezeigt
und warum leichter darüber so weit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist eine kurze aufnahme von meiner
musik
[Musik]
ich habe mich nicht erschrocken
das traurige ist halt das wird das jetzt
gerade alle lustig finden und witzig und
süß aber so wird halt wirklich der
sommer dies ja aussehen
[Musik]
220 highlight kann ich meine erfahrungen
und zwar ist die akustiker und ich bin
sicher dass wir durch die meist nicht
haben und deswegen gegen das jetzt
versuchen
dazu fällt mir wirklich nur ein quality
content gemeldet
[Musik]
erst mal leute neigen ja ich meine
freunde wer kennt es nicht mehr wenn man
in einer online video konferenz ist oder
eine hausparty zoom facetime skype
whatever dass man sich verabschiedet
dies komme immer wenn ich im bus hier
ist das bei mir so wie viele buchstaben
des alphabets 26 hervorragend sie haben
den test bestanden der nächste
buchstaben haben sie keine ahnung woher
ich muss wissen dass ein paar meter
ja
heftige kämpfe mit facebook postest du
[Musik]
hast geberit auf jeden fall verstanden
und die nächste person hat zwar
verstanden aber die lache von der
nächsten person ist legendär also schaut
sagen wir machen jetzt gebe es bei fast
all access lvr fast gleichmäßig durch
ein model a durch die nada hatte er hat
das schon vorher wahrscheinlich
wen willst du hier veräppelt
ich möchte auch mal schauen ja gleich
neben die jetzt
[Applaus]
von den nun ich weiß ist dass sie
deutsche sind zwei sie hier kennt da
habe ich jeder beteiligen kann dieser
wert muss durch die nacht dann natürlich
burkhard opera deutsche schauspieler und
sänger willi schmidt der tänzer und
choreograph daniel johansson kommt aus
hamburg dann johann depp kanzlerkandidat
2005 und zu guter letzt leonard die
capri-sonne gründer von capri sonne
ja sagt einmal das nächste jetzt warum
hast du so viele hunde und könntest du
mir vielleicht einen abgeben mach einen
finger hunderte schon mal ein mädchen
auf der straße begegnet bist dass eine
schildkröte im abendrot und dusche
gründen absolut system das also
hingegangen ist um sie gefragt hast du
simon halten kannst und damit ihr
genauer ansehen kannst weil du dir
vielleicht auch eine schildkröte zulegen
möchtest sichern aber dann
herausgestellt hat dass du einfach nur
maximal sehr beeinträchtigt ist und dass
ein sandwich ist was sie in der hand
hält und du sie somit gefragt hat ob wir
jetzt wo ich mal halten kannst und
genauer an die katze ich wirklich
absolut gar nichts mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie gesagt ich freue mich wirklich
nichts mehr
[Applaus]
irgendwie setzt uns die quarantäne ganz
schön zu google
hu
dieser clip beschreiben wenn das bitte
eigene fanpage oder mime seite klippen
und mich drauf instagram darauf
verlinken
das nicht verklebt hat meinen kanal
gerade 1 2 zusammengefasst
[Musik]
das war ein sinnbild für meine schulzeit
ja und zwar war diese katze die da vor
ihm darüber gesprochen über jede reihe
das irgendwie geschafft hat das waren
sie die ganzen streber die die klassen
aufgaben in mathe et cetera verstanden
haben waren zuerst aufgabe zeit aufgabe
dritte aufgabe vierte aufgabe indien
dann ist so ja erst aufgabe gerade und
weise geht schon komplett geht da ja
kaum haben wir hier das nächste tik tok
rhein wo ein typ wieder eine challenge
nicht so richtig verstanden hat
[Musik]
ja und das nächste tik tok
ist wieder von marvin ist fertig
[Musik]
ich kann nicht mal einen runden kreis
zeichnen und der macht also einen
hollywood film
er kennt ihr diese wasser hilfe die
studiert haben ist hier gibt es wasser
dann biss da wärme kälte auf einmal gibt
es ja auch desinfektionsmittel
ich habe das gleiche problem einer
zahnbürste ich bin einfach nur dass die
elektrisch ist mir die zähne putzt auf
einmal die das sensitive clean mai
intensiv oder stuhlgang schatz ich habe
mal ein auge auf dich jetzt halt den
schnabel den schnabel super jetzt halt
die klappe klappe dann ankermieter in
den thunfisch
[Musik]
das ist ein neuer trend die nicht auf
die beobachtung konnte uns was die
french language challenge so heißt es
glaube ich und zwar klingen auf
französisch viele leute viele viele
leute viele wörter sehr ähnlich also ich
zeige euch noch zwei videos von allen
[Musik]
wer für mich auch gut weil ich habe bald
wieder nach frankreich ziehen wir sind
jetzt wieder ein herz und eine will ich
und mein freund haben kritik heraus und
zwar wenn diese lösen kann
macht mal dann geht es sein willst du
ein tief mal raus es ist ja für ganz
danke für die weisheit des tages
wirklich alle interessiert kommen wir
nun allerdings auch schon im letzten
sektor fürs heutige video meiner liebe
freuen uns was ist eine person die
extrem gut zauns nachmachen kann und er
zeigt uns auch wirklich dass es seine
stimme ist indem er das erst mit dem
mikro wirklich veranschaulicht und dann
macht er eine londoner u-bahn also
schaut einfach selbst
[Musik]
diesmal gab's trine train annika vom
visit the city will ein service team
haben es mir aus gesehen
[Musik]
ich kann nicht mein hund nachmachen
und 10
es würde mich das sollte sich jetzt aber
ändern wenn die lieben freunde wenn euch
die heute am dienstag gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unternehmen
schreibt mir euren tipp topp nach unten
in die kommentare wenn ihr eventuell in
die nächste folge ticketings
hereinkommen wollt jetzt befinden uns
allerdings auch schon im auto und zwar
könnte hier oben einfach mal auf den
smiley draufklicken wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanalseite dann
verpasse keine videos mehr und es ist
kostenlos und die crew das auf jeden
fall super und hier ist ein video auf
meinem zweit kanal verlinkt also hier
könnt ihr auch draufklicken das ist
soeben online gegangen also schauts euch
jahren hier haben